les femmes et les enfants d'abord les
hommes seuls pourraient devoir attendre
une sélection qui rassure certains
canadiens mais qui en inquiète d'autres
faire un tri de cette manière et exclure
les hommes célibataires
ça ne fait que confirmer et perpétuer ce
mythe que le jeune musulman et arabe et
syrien est interdite ce même si le
gouvernement refuse de confirmer qu'il
fermera les portes du canada aux hommes
syrie un célibataire pour bien des
experts cela n'aurait rien d'inhabituel
on sait pratique courante de
sélectionner les gens qui sont les plus
vulnérables
olivier avisait et chercheur associé à
l'observatoire canadien sur les crises
et l'aide humanitaire de l'uqam
généralement les hommes seuls
généralement ceux qui sont un peu plus
jeunes aussi arrivent très bas dans la
liste de priorités les premières
touchées les provinces qui ont fait de
l'accueil des réfugiés un des thèmes de
leur rencontre avec le fédéral je
penserai pas que cette règle soit
absolue cependant je vous rappellerai
que le haut commissariat des nations
unies dans sa sélection sur
l'établissement du statut de réfugié 50
degré de vulnérabilité des gens ce qui
l'amène à placer en tête de priorité les
familles avec enfants et également les
membres des minorités religieuses
opprimés actuellement au moyen orient
selon des organismes le gouvernement
annoncerait qu'il est prêt à accueillir
les hommes gais identifiés comme
particulièrement vulnérables
le premier ministre du nouveau-brunswick
lui s'en remet aux mesures d'ottawa faut
faire confiance au gouvernement fédéral
qui ont des renseignements en sécurité
qui doit aide à développer les
politiques pour jouer notre rôle au
niveau international lorsque ça vient
une crise humaine comme celui-ci
ce projet national consiste à faire
preuve de leadership
à la sortie de leur rencontre avec
justin trudeau les premiers ministres se
sont montrés confiants sur la question
de la sécurité il faut savoir que c'est
fait de façon excessivement serré sans
compromis et de la bonne façon
autant sur cette question que sur la
question du financement
ce soir le ministre qui pilote le
dossier des réfugiés giancarlo incite à
la prudence
devant les nombreuses rumeurs qui
circulent depuis quelques jours le
cabinet doit approuver le plan final
demain matin et c'est en fin de journée
qui sera finalement dévoilée aux
canadiens ici marc godbout radio canada
ottawa